we have a voicemail number which is 2192
David P here is a voicemail from the man
we know is the most chaotic caller of
all time Billy Harrison and
um this caller is a great example of why
the United States isn't a better country
Okay let's listen
David packman Billy Harrison here uh
Colin again
I'm calling on the fact that you just
I'm watching your little live video that
you had with Trump because I've watched
a live video already but I kind of go
back and watch yours because you you
laugh at it really me and my wife uh I
called a while back and kind of asked
you to me and you debate live but you
refuse to do it as I've said before
Billy you can call in when we take live
calls I mean I'm not what do you debate
live I'm not gonna fly to wherever you
live and debate you in person if you
call in any time and confront me about
whatever uh
but you're claiming about the bio labs
in Ukraine that someone has to prove it
that there's no evidence of it now see
we talked about this earlier I'm not
claiming anyone has to prove that
there's no evidence of it what I'm
explaining is that no one has brought
forth any evidence that the labs in
Ukraine are in any way unique or
pernicious relative to all the other
labs that do pathogen research all over
Europe and all over the world and it
certainly is no justification for the
Russian invasion that's the issue
somebody commented and called you out on
that about Tucker Carlson saying that it
that it you know that it was true and it
was important and
you said that it is stupid for someone
to basically say you know start saying
stuff like that without no evidence
is anybody else even following this
but you don't have no evidence that an
answer and of course this gets us to the
exact uh Russell's teapot principle that
I mentioned earlier people who don't
have any understanding of what we what
the burden of proof mechanism is and my
I'm not going to go Point Counterpoint
with Billy Harrison but what I do want
to mention is
if someone so misunderstands what is
even being said how do we even talk to
these people they don't even it's not
that we disagree about our analysis
the guy doesn't even have any idea
what's been said he's wrong about what
Tucker said he's wrong about what I said
how there's no shared basis of fact it's
a very sad situation in this country
very very sad we've got a great bonus
though for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com to get access oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad we will see you then